i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
there is a very interesting new poll out
a 2024 poll in which joe biden is
leading donald trump by six now why do
we care about that it's september of
2022. well there are a number of
different reasons one is that like no
election i can remember
we are already sort of in the 2024
election and usually each election is a
very kind of compartmentalized with very
clear boundaries election and in this
case it is very different as much of
what is already happening now
bears directly on 2024 it's also
something we care about because donald
trump's refrain has been i'm winning
every poll now
we don't know if trump is running we
don't know if joe biden is running so
what it would even mean to lead a poll
is a question but it is not true that
donald trump is leading every poll let's
take a look uh the hill reporting new
poll shows biden with six point lead on
trump biden is leading trump by six in a
hypothetical
2024 presidential matchup new polling
shows in a yahoo news yougov poll
released yesterday wednesday
48 percent of registered voters said
they'd vote biden if the election were
today and 42 percent say they'd vote
trump now that's only 90 percent of the
electorate meaning there's still another
10 percent in flux that is often the
case in these polls
biden held a three-point lead in the
hypothetical 2020 rematch in august from
august to september biden's lead has
gone from three to six
now again
the a bunch of different caveats first
of all this is just one poll
if we look at more polls you'll see that
trump is leading some of them but more
recently biden's leading all of them if
you look at an emerson poll from about
two weeks ago it's biden plus one
if you look at a wall street journal
poll from about two and a half weeks ago
it's biden plus six
and then before that you had trump
leading three polls in a row one of
which was an admittedly right-leaning
trafalgar group poll so it is not the
only poll this new poll in which joe
biden is leading but what i want to
focus on is the absurdity of what is
going on in the united states trump
belongs in prison
more than he belongs on presidential
polls the idea that trump might even
have a shot at the republican nomination
is
extraordinarily disturbing
and embarrassing for the country
this is a guy who should never be
running again for anything he shouldn't
be allowed to run again based on the
things that he that he's done
and instead he's
in it in a hypothetical matchup for the
presidency
and it says way more about the voters
than it does about donald trump himself
and so as i always say
it's time to start getting your friends
your family and your community
um aware of the fact that they must vote
and what better way to warm up to voting
in 2024 than voting in 2022 as i said
before because the concern of course is
and this is why i started this segment
by saying in a way that isn't typical
this election and 2024 are kind of
running together
the 2024 election
is going to be greatly influenced by
what happens now in more ways than one
yes
if there is a big magat
uh
running of the table in november
that emboldens trump for 2024 and it
does build the strength of the maga
movement for 2024 so maga people are on
the ballot if they lose it's bad for
trump if they win it's good for trump in
2024 but there's a much more disgusting
way in which the november election bears
directly on 24 which is there are people
who might win in november
who will help trump steal the election
in 2024. at the top of the list of
course is republican gubernatorial
nominee for pennsylvania doug mastriano
masteriano as i've told you before and i
know many of you have already heard this
masteriano was at the january 6th riot
and mastriano is a big lie proponent
and if indeed masteriano is the governor
in november of 2024 and the democratic
nominee wins pennsylvania by a few
points mastriano
will
try to steal pennsylvania for the
republican candidate he will try
and i rarely make predictions because
there's so much left to circumstance and
possibility and probability
masteriano will try to steal
pennsylvania's electors in 2024 for the
republican if it's a republican that you
know he's in league with like trump and
that's why this is such an important
midterm election trump stole
nuclear documents classified documents
top secret documents to do who the hell
knows what with
and he's polling in the 40s he's polling
in the 40s
among registered voters in the united
states humiliating
and the world sees it
now
if we want to find some good news in the
data it's that democrats
keep gaining on republicans
in 2022 election polling
the numbers are not yet a delight
but they're increasingly looking okay
let's start with the house why start
with the house well democrats are not
favored to keep control of the house
democrats currently control the house of
representatives it is likely that they
will lose the house of representatives
but
the numbers have been improving for
democrats every single day for months
where do the numbers stand now the 538
forecast for the house
says that it's a 74 chance that
republicans take the house and a 26
percent chance that democrats keep the
house but
look at the way the numbers have shifted
if you scroll down on this 538 page
which is a very very uh detailed and
it's a great forecast you will see a
section called how the house forecast is
changed
and you will see that in early june
democrats had a 14 chance of holding the
house that even dropped to 12
in late june early july but it has been
a steady but
you know modest surge
almost doubling the odds of democrats
keeping the house going from uh actually
more than doubling going from a bottom
out of 12 to a 26 chance now remember
things that are 12 percent likely to
happen sometimes happen things that are
26 percent likely to happen sometimes
happen but things that are 74 percent
likely to happen are are more likely to
happen by definition so i can't tell you
that i think it's a great shot for
democrats in the house but the numbers
have been improving and if democrats
keep adding on you know one percentage
point chance every other day between now
and november
uh that's 30 right that would put this
at 50 50 by election day so that's
what's happening in the house now in the
senate things are looking much better
for democrats in the senate democrats
are now
70 percent chance uh 70 likely to hold
control of the senate whereas
republicans are only 30 likely this has
gone last week i told you it was two to
one in favor of democrats it is now
two and a third or you know whatever
it's it's well beyond two to one at this
point in time and again
these are numbers that have improved for
democrats uh there was a point in early
june where democrats had a 40
shot of holding the senate that is now a
70 shot very very important to
understand because there are people
writing to me saying david why do you
keep saying democrats are going to have
70 senators
and of course david is not saying that
what i am telling you is that it is a 70
chance
that democrats hold the senate the most
likely outcome
is that democrats hold it
51-49 that would be a gain of one seat
right now in the senate it's 50 50.
the vice president gets a tie-breaking
vote that's kamala harris so democrats
are in the majority
50 50 plus kamala the most likely
outcome here is a 51 to 49 majority for
democrats so please do not write to me
saying david
democrats have no chance in hell of
getting 70 seats
i'm agreeing with you that's not what
the number means that's not what the
number means
but i appreciate everybody writing in so
the bottom line
democrats chances continuing to improve
and if they merely continue improving at
the same rate
the house will end up a 50 50-50 flip of
the coin
by early november we will watch and see
whether that happens
let's now take a look at the flavor of
what's going on in some congressional
races among republicans and i will tell
you it is absolutely sick
last night
republicans debated
in the new hampshire first district
uh
in the new hampshire first district race
there were five republicans up on the
stage
four of them said they would impeach joe
biden on day one
what
impeach him for what well that they
don't agree on you really have to see
this and this is really indicative of
the
brazen
partisan unhinged nature of the
republican party at this point in time
you are going to hear in a moment from
tim baxter
caroline levitt russell prescott and
gail huff brown
all of whom are ready to impeach joe
biden the day they get into congress if
they do
now the fifth republican here matt
mowers
he's not ready to say impeach yet but he
certainly thinks we need hearings to
figure out whether to impeach joe biden
i know it's extraordinarily disturbing
it's extraordinarily sad let's take a
listen would you vote to impeach
president biden for anything he's done
so far in office absolutely
yes the dereliction of duty at our
southern border he's allowed for an
invasion of our country
now remember
almost nothing has changed at the
southern border
from trump to biden other than as the
pandemic eased
more people started to try to come to
the united states
there has been and some families have
been reunited that were separated under
trump there has been no
real change but these republicans want
you to think there's been some 180 at
the border trade his oath of the
constitution and our homeland is of
brown the commander-in-chief has one job
to protect americans at home and abroad
and he did not protect americans in
afghanistan that was the day i got into
the race so remember that the
they don't know they're not sure why
they don't agree on why
but they know bide needs to be impeached
one it's because of what he did at the
southern border oh well actually no it's
because of what he did in afghanistan
which by the way is the same thing trump
would have done all right that's three
for three councillor prescott yes i
would four for four and matt we do have
to have hearings to look into these
things the fact that you have the
president and secretary of defense lying
to the american people about
intelligence reports coming out of
afghanistan has to be looked into would
you so four out of five say yes i would
impeach on day one i would vote to
impeach now
and number five out of five says
i've got to do hearings we must do
hearings in order to figure out whether
to impeach
oh boy so it's the border it's their
election of duty it's afghanistan or
it's just not really clear why
understand that we have an economy right
now that is essentially at full
employment we have consumer demand for
all sorts of products and services off
the charts demand for doctors is off the
charts demand for electricians is off
the charts demand for plumbers is off
the charts demand for car detailing is
off the charts
uh we are out of afghanistan
which trump was going to do two jobs
reports in a row with significantly
greater than expected jobs numbers gas
declining 26 over a two two and a half
month period as rapid a decline as we
have ever seen in gas prices inflation
coming down with an inflation report
coming out tuesday which i expect is
going to be uh pretty pretty good
um
inflation reduction act a packed act i
could go on and on and on
and the absolute political theater
taking place among the republican party
has four out of five republicans
outright saying i would impeach him
right now and a fifth saying well we
should at least look into it with some
peerings and the most important takeaway
here is you know there's the optics of
the cartoonish nature of this and that
is not something to be ignored it is
cartoonish and it's a joke
but there's a bigger story here that is
a broader republican story
what is the policy vision for the
republican party that they've
articulated i would ask over the last
six months
over the last two years
over the last six years
increasingly there is no policy it's
we've got to stop
marxism we've got to stop woke
we've got to impeach biden it's
dereliction of duty
there the country is going to hell as
donald trump you'll hear him on indian
tv this is going to be a rare treat for
you on indian tv donald trump saying the
country is going to hell
and it's all about appeasing the most
extreme unhinged elements of their party
and i want to remind people the new
hampshire first district in fact i want
to be accurate about this new hampshire
first district
2020 presidential results
um
in the new hampshire first congressional
district
in 2020
this was a
uh
trump won it in 2016
but then biden won it quite easily yeah
biden won it by six in 2020. this is not
like an extreme district now these are
republicans i understand the republicans
there may be extreme
this is a this is a district that voted
biden pretty handily for what's
considered a purple state new hampshire
in 2020
and yet they are still kowtowing to the
most extreme elements of the republican
party will that work in the general i
mean probably not but it is political
theater all meant to appease their dear
orange leader and it's pathetic i want
to remind you that on 9 19
we are doing a 19 themed membership
special if you've been thinking well
david i kind of like the show i like the
idea of the bonus show regardless of
what alex jones says oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad right if that has tickled your
fancy but you're just waiting for the
right moment to strike
get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
and on 9 19
you'll get a beautiful email a perfect
email telling you how to avail yourself
of an extraordinary membership discount
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
imagine this scenario you try logging
into your email account to see that your
password was changed a few hours ago
except you didn't do it and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and from your credit cards but you
didn't do any of it that is what
identity theft is like it can happen
very quickly and if you don't act fast
it can get worse we've dealt with this
at the david pakman show you can find
videos about it and that's why i protect
myself now using aura our sponsor aura
is identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management and an
antivirus all in one easy to use app
aura will monitor the dark web for your
emails passwords and social security
numbers and will send you alerts quickly
to your phone and email aura also gives
you near real-time alerts on suspicious
credit inquiries like if someone was
opening a loan or a credit card in your
name and if you sign up at aura.com
pacman you will get a free two-week
trial which you can use to see if your
login credentials have been leaked
online
i would want to know that right away use
the link below
let's talk a little bit about the
special master that has been appointed
by judge eileen cannon to oversee the
documents seized at donald trump's house
there's really no way to put it lightly
uh best levin has a very good article in
vanity fair called trump's special
master situation is shady as f
according to legal experts now i
encourage you to check out the entire
article because it will go into a lot
more detail than i will go into today
but as many of you who have emailed me
have suspected
the legal reasoning for the special
master being granted is extraordinarily
shaky and as many legal experts have
weighed in it will really do nothing
other than slightly delay the process
of this criminal investigation into
donald trump now that shouldn't be
dismissed as nothing donald trump's
strategy for many years legally has been
delay any opportunity you have to delay
is good and most lawyers will agree that
at least as far as the clients they
represent right
if you ask them about some case they're
not involved in
most of them will say you know the delay
tactics don't typically help over the
long term but there are lawyers who will
say well listen what i know is if i can
delay i give myself an opportunity to
mount to better defense allow people to
quit retire get bored get frustrated
whatever so delay is usually considered
something that uh lawyers like to do and
that they can bill for by the way so
best levin reports judge eileen cannon a
granted this request from donald trump's
legal team for a special master a
special master reviews the documents
holds and reviews the documents in this
case it's 11 000 government documents
that were seized from mar-a-lago on
august 8th and the reason that this is
advantageous to trump at least in theory
is that while the documents are under
the review of the special master
prosecutors can't continue using those
documents and examining the documents
for their criminal investigation the
review has to happen first
trump's claim
is that some of the materials are
covered by executive privilege
some of the materials are
medical documents etc
legal experts by and large believe that
the ruling is absurd for a couple of
different reasons first let's start with
samuel buell who's a duke university law
professor he spoke to the new york times
and said quote
to any lawyer with serious federal
criminal court experience who is being
honest this ruling is laughably bad and
the written justification is even
flimsier donald trump is getting
something no one else ever gets in
federal court he's getting it for no
good reason and it will not in the
slightest reduce the ongoing howls that
he is being persecuted when he is being
privileged that's a really important
point
trump's story is
i am being treated uniquely terribly by
the justice system the reality is he's
being treated uniquely well
the fact that the justice department and
fbi
waited so long
to do the search warrant
after they requested the documents from
trump under subpoena and they weren't
turned over that is a privilege that was
granted to donald trump the fact that
the special master has been appointed is
a privilege for donald trump
constitutional law professor lawrence
tribe wrote about judge eileen cannon's
decision her decision was utterly
lawless she is disgraced she has
disgraced her position
as an article iii judge
and then
um u.s former u.s acting solicitor
general neil katyal wrote on twitter
this special master opinion is so bad
it's hard to know where to begin
she says biden hasn't weighed in on
whether documents are protected by
executive privilege nonsense the
archives letter makes it clear the
current president thinks none of this is
privileged the archivist says it is not
a close question
two the judge enjoins the entire
investigation because some of the
material might be subject to executive
privilege but executive privilege isn't
some post-presidential privilege that
allows presidents to keep documents
after they leave office
at most it simply means these are
executive documents that must be
returned to the archives it doesn't in
any way shape or form mean they can't be
used in a criminal prosecution about
stolen documents and lastly this is an
important point judge cannon said that
the reputational harm to trump from the
documents
justifies a special master and katyal
says that's insane every criminal
defendant has reputational harm are we
now going to have special masters in
every criminal investigation and that's
a really important point
one of the big statements made by judge
eileen cannon is
the reputational harm that trump would
suffer or might suffer from these
documents being given to the fbi
potentially made public etc
justifies a special master getting all
the documents and reviewing them
arguably anytime you are
rated and potentially indicted
by the federal government
you're going to suffer reputationally
even if the charges are ultimately
dropped this is one of the things that
is sort of a
i don't know what to call it a calling
card it's it's a feature
or a bug whatever of our justice system
which is sometimes people are arrested
and charged and then they are found not
guilty or charges are dismissed
and there is still the risk of and
sometimes there really is reputational
harm if you're accused of murder
and charged with murder and then there's
a lengthy trial and you're acquitted
it's not like everything goes back to
zero because you were found not guilty
and you can argue that that's a problem
with our justice system it's a problem
arguably with many justice systems which
is you can be charged and and there can
be a trial and then you're acquitted but
the fact that you were charged still
hurts you in some way reputationally
it's not unique to donald trump and the
idea as neil katyal points out arguably
anytime this happens to any defendant
there's reputational harm you're not
going to grant a special master in all
cases is another one of the signs that
donald trump isn't being persecuted
unfairly he's actually being privileged
he is being deferred to and given things
that so many others so many other
defendants are not
speaking of defendants stephen bannon is
expected today to surrender and be
indicted
again
over the cash for the border wall scam
that he participated in this is very
interesting cnn reporting steve bannon
is expected to surrender today
to face new york state charges related
to his fundraising effort to build a
wall along the southern u.s border
remember this was the scam in which when
it became clear trump wasn't going to
build the wall and mexico wasn't going
to pay for it etc etc
um
some individuals including bannon
participated in a give us cash and will
build the wall thing and it was a total
scam
the state charges which have been
returned in an indictment are based on
the same conduct bannon was charged with
by federal prosecutors in 2020. if this
rings a bell
it's because indeed bannon was already
charged federally for this then
president donald trump pardoned bannon
on those charges as he was leaving
office
presidential pardons do not apply to
state investigations
robert costello an attorney for bannon
said wednesday that the former trump
aide is expected to plead not guilty
when he is arraigned the washington port
post first reported bannon's plans to
surrender
um
and then the other stuff i mean you got
you guys probably would uh understand or
expect all the other stuff bannon calls
the charges phony he says it's partisan
he says it's political weaponization he
says he's a leading voice to protect our
borders he says in fact i have not yet
begun to fight they will have to kill me
first which are certainly fighting words
there are two sides to this and i want
to remind you about the two and by by
the way by two sides i don't mean
there's two sides as to whether what
bannon did was wrong that's not what i
mean there's two aspects to this first
of all
does the evidence point to bannon
participating in a fraud it does that's
why he was indicted um federally
and that's why he is now being indicted
at the state level it is correct the
evidence points to it he should not
receive special treatment if the
evidence is there you must indict and
that's what's happening
the second part of this is
the victims of the fraud the victims of
the scam and we've talked about this
before remember that to make an analogy
after the 2020 election
when joe biden won and was clearly going
to become the president no matter what
donald trump tried to do
uh donald trump started fundraising on
send me money and i will do audits and i
will do recounts and i will do legal
challenges and of course i knew and many
of you knew those were going nowhere and
if you look at the fine print a bunch of
that money was being used by trump to
pay off campaign debt and there was this
rich guy who donated i think it was like
250 000 maybe it was even more
who then sued and said i got scammed i
should get my money back because i got
scammed by trump and we said at the time
republicans constantly talk about buyer
beware and you can't have a nanny state
protecting everybody from everything so
should this guy really be allowed to sue
in this way now of course he's allowed
but it could be dismissed or whatever
found against him
there's a similar aspect here
um in the same way that fox news argues
no one should seriously consider the
things tucker says to be literally true
he's doing entertainment you could make
the case that no one should really have
believed that steve bannon was going to
help fundraise for a privately funded
and privately built wall with mexico
it's absurd it doesn't make any sense
you'd have to be a [ __ ] to fall for
that
and so as a result of that
what what sort of protection what sort
of relief from the state
should the people that were scammed get
i don't believe that just because you're
a republican you deserve to be scammed i
don't believe that but there's a real
question about this is so absurd
that does it really warrant
relief for the people that were scammed
and if so what would that relief be i
don't know the answer but i want to hear
from you we'll have more on this and all
of our other stories from today on the
david pakman show instagram yes you can
find our instagram at david pakman show
and you can also find some really wacky
hate mail i've gotten in the last few
days
on my instagram i am david dot pakman on
instagram that's a period not like
spelling out dot
david dot pakman find me there
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount
joinpakman.com
alright as many of you know
um one of the races that i find to
really point to
just the absurdity of the united states
of america is the georgia senate race in
which incumbent democratic senator
rafael warnock is being challenged by a
man who has already won the republican
primary race his name is herschel walker
he used to be a football player and one
of the reasons that i find this race so
disturbing is that herschel walker quite
literally cannot speak herschel water
walker is incoherent herschel walker
cannot explain his views on any
political issue herschel walker will not
debate raphael warnock but is starting
to claim that warnock is actually the
one who won't debate him
it is
extraordinarily disturbing because you
have a man who quite literally cannot
speak it's impossible to know what he
thinks about anything
and he's only down like a point
to the incumbent democratic senator
rafael warnock
take a look at some of these new clips
that i have
from herschel walker
at a rally i guess it's called a rally
although it's not clear whether i mean
this could be a eulogy or a rally you
can't tell it's it's not clear whether
this is a happy event or a sad event or
what because it's not clear what he's
talking about here is herschel walker
talking about a bull in a field with six
cows
tell me if you can understand what he's
talking about here tell you this little
story i heard one time
it's about everybody thinking something
is better somewhere else
and i remember talking about this boy
that was out in the field
and he had six cows with him
three of them were expecting cats
he had these six cows but what he was
worried about he kept his nose up
against the fence seeing these other
three cows up on the hillside
oh is this like a grass's greener
parable so as he's looking up on the
hillside of these other three cows not
worrying about what he got now the grass
is as tall as his knees all he had to do
is eat grass
but he worried about something else
and so one day
he measured that fence up
he measured that fence up and he said
you know i think i could jump this fence
and get over there and those other cows
now don't worry about what he got i can
jump it i'm gonna get over there
so as he got back went out the new he
took off running and he dove
and as he made it over the fences better
got all cut up and stuff he rolled up
and he got up and he knew he would have
made it on the other side he was so
excited about it
and then he ran to the top of the hill
when he got up there he realized that
they were bulls too
and the reason i tell you that
don't think something is better
somewhere else okay i mean i guess he's
saying in a very strange way
don't fall for the grasses greener on
the other side and i okay fine um here's
another story
of a guy who got to the pearly gates
and it was a trick of some kind and this
is about this story of this
[Music]
man that died and he went to heaven
early
and when he got to heaven saint peter
met him at the pearly gates
and saint peter said you're here early
right now
and your name ain't on the road
but he said i'm going to give you an
opportunity
to decide where you want to go
he said you can go to heaven or you can
go to hell and i'm gonna give you a
chance to decide for yourself
and he puts him in his elevator and he
takes him all the way down to hell
and the doors open up
and there's a party going on
there's a lot of his friends down there
and they're having a good time
and so after a couple of hours ago saint
peter came to him and said uh we got to
leave now we got to leave he said we got
to go he's in here you got to go right
now
so he puts him in this elevator he takes
him all the way up to heaven
and they get to heaven and the doors
open up
and there's people floating around on
clouds
they're having a good time
after a couple of hours saint peter came
to him and said are you ready to make
the decision
and the guy said well saint pete
i need to tell you this
but i think i want to go to hell
he said are you sure he's a yeah
really has a way with words it seems
like my type of place
so he puts him in his elevator
they go all the way down the hill now
when the doors open up now it's hot
hotter than today is hot
people are looking miserable they're
terrible
they're just crying okay i'm not going
to subject you to the uh to the rest of
it folks uh
this guy's polling 46 in georgia i'm
sorry 45 in georgia
um right now if you look at polling
georgia senate herschel walker versus
raphael warnock
walker is only behind by on average one
point in fact the latest poll from
emerson
has walker ahead by two
now
maybe you don't agree with everything
raphael warnock stands for
maybe you don't like all of his policy
positions but we send 100 people to the
u.s senate and some intellectual
capacity and cognitive ability
should be a requirement and this is not
about you know i know every time we talk
about this david well you're making fun
of people who have mental illness does
walker have mental illness and i'm not
making fun of that you're making fun of
people who have a brain injury does
walker have a brain injury i'm not
making fun of that or what
this is a position
that has certain intellectual
requirements or at least it should so
it's even if those things were true
about herschel walker it would still not
be a reason to make him a united states
senator
here's one bonus
here's walker i guess outlining his
educational plan in our school you've
seen it
all kids are behind because they want to
be woke
they want to be warm
what about teaching them how to write
what about teaching them how to read
what about teaching them how to spell
yeah but right now we've elected people
to watch that want to profit
off the bikes or the misery they're
given to us yeah
um woke profits are the reason
i guess school is bad at this point in
time so
i know people have been emailing me
emailing me and saying david you know
i've seen a lot of morons be elected to
public office you know i was around for
the bush era and then trump
but
there's something about if walker wins
that they will be completely despondent
and i have to tell you that i get it i
really do
speaking of disoriented i want to play
for you clips of a visibly disoriented
sarah palin now you might remember that
sarah palin was the late john mccain's
vice presidential running mate back in
2008.
thankfully they lost and she was kind of
like the opening of the door to
cartoonish trumpism where like anything
goes in some way palin was the
predecessor to people like trump madison
cawthorne marjory trader greene lauren
beaubert herschel walker as we saw
the normalization of people in
completely over their heads in politics
she recently lost her election trying to
become a congresswoman representing
alaska in the house of representatives
of washington dc she recently lost that
and she appeared on the steve bannon
real america's voice
war room pandemic show whatever that is
and she seems to be completely
disoriented she doesn't know what the
hell is going on she attacks rank choice
voting
it's completely wild and this was a
woman who was almost a heartbeat away
from the presidency of the united states
think about that well you called it
steve when you explained what this
newfangled cockamamie system
called ranked choice voting is all about
when it doesn't matter
if you perhaps are the most popular or
most qualified candidate uh no it
you can get a whole lot of votes steve
but if you don't get enough second or
third rankings from voters who choose
another candidate
listening to sarah palin explain ranked
choice voting is absolutely delightful
in that she has no idea what's going on
she doesn't even understand the system
under which she lost
she just has no idea what it's even
about
it
you can get a whole lot of votes steve
but if you don't get enough second or
third rankings from voters who choose
another candidate right then you're
eliminated or then you get second place
and you don't win and it's complicated
you explained it best president trump
explained it very well yeah trump really
explained this concept well he also
explained you know thermodynamics really
well just like she would i'm sure rally
that he had up here
warning alaskans that this newfangled
experiment
with ranked choice voting will split
votes it will allow liberals to skip on
in which is exactly what's happened thus
far they can just skip on in and vote by
the way this was trump's explanation for
rank choice voting fraud
fraud fraud
it's a fraud that was his brilliant
explanation
and um it's a it's a very very uh
potentially fraught with fraud
she has no idea to this day why and how
she lost she genuinely has no clue
um and then of course she
these people want to use anger they need
everybody to be angry that's how they
operate and here is sarah palin in this
same interview and by the way why sarah
palin's homes are like the most echoey
places ever it's like a cave i i've
never understood but here's sarah palin
in her echoey house
saying people should be angry she lost
that harms the entire nation so i think
the entire country should be angry at
what's going on with this establishment
system and it was the political
establishment that created this system
with the rank choice voting and without
encouraging the other republican to drop
out once he got thumbed three times
others should be outraged about what's
going on here right
our system is harming the rest of the
u.s the uh everything everything that
has a bad outcome to these people is
fraudulent and um it's sort of the same
argument that they would make if we
figured out a way to get rid of the
electoral college and just have a
national popular vote which we should we
obviously should uh they would say oh
that's harming the country really how is
it how would it harm the country that
the candidate with the most votes wins
well it's not the will of the found
it's the exact same type of thing if the
system leads to me losing it's a bad
system and sarah palin
there's almo there is something comedic
about the fact that she doesn't even get
how and why she lost and there's an
amazing video from election night a
couple weeks ago
where
she's
like wherever her watch party her
results party is
and the information starts coming in
that she lost and she doesn't even
really get it and at one point she goes
over and she cuts a cake and just the
absurdity the visual absurdity of she
doesn't really know what's going on but
they do have a cake there and she's
going to move on to the cake it is
really something to see
they don't have any clue what's
happening and there are a number of
systems in this country that should be
reformed
and our voting systems are some of them
and we have to realize that even if they
were to be changed you would then deal
with years of confused people claiming
that by virtue of the fact that they
lost it must be a bad system and
certainly sarah palin is buying into
that full speed ahead
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com david
pakman show as a general rule trump plus
india is a very dangerous combination
likely to lead to complete and total
humiliation trump when he is alongside
indian prime minister modi will often
praise extraordinarily authoritarian
ideas you might remember that once
donald trump spoke in india and
mispronounced everything
and the crowd literally started to flee
you might remember our 2020 video indian
crowd flees as trump mispronounces
everything remember trump trying to
pronounce indian names foreign
[Applause]
yeah that that was a hell of an event
yes
so anyway trump went on indian tv
yesterday uh ndtv new delhi television
and just drops humiliating whopper after
whopper now i still don't really know
why he's appearing on these shows
i think that
there's probably
less interest lately in having him on
you know what might be more mainstream
american outlets that's an interesting
question in and of itself but donald
trump appearing alongside the indian
prime minister modi and trump says a lot
of crazy things including that the
united states is quote going to hell
overall the president trump that's the
question that keeps coming up that in a
democracy india is considered the
world's largest democracy you're the
world's oldest and that's why we have
this relationship the democracies
function on the principle that the
losing side concedes the defeat and the
winning side i agree with it that
when you lose in this case you haven't
cons i mean in a sense you still haven't
accepted the outcome of 2020 no because
i look at the rules take a look at what
happened
two weeks ago it came out the head of
facebook
zuckerberg said the app they had a
facebook guys bi came to him
and told him this
russian disinformation
don't say anything and they went to the
media and they suppressed it
that's a major form this isn't just
ballot stuffing what they're doing right
was so bad and what they're doing uh see
if you can follow his explanation
through the entire clip i dare you is it
disgrace to our country uh and nobody
did anything about it and it made they
say the pollsters say it made from a 10
to a 20 point difference
can you imagine can you imagine what
he's claiming there a 20-point
difference because of uh of of the
hunter biden laptop zuckerberg thing so
instead of biden winning by
well i don't even know what was the
percentage six trump was going to win
the popular vote by 14. i mean it's an
absurd claim in the election outcome oh
it was a tremendous they suppressed all
of that information
probably illegally i assume it was
illegally done but it should have never
done next
you you think that this is a kind of a
problematic area when
you have an electronic outcome and then
absolutely not one side doesn't accept
no absolutely not you know i mean we all
know there is a lot of fraud voter fraud
in the united states you know all the
democrat-run cities uh democrat-run
districts sorry and by the way if i said
earlier that uh
um
trump appeared alongside modi this is
not modi it's very clearly not modi and
i don't know why i have that in my notes
but this is shalab kumar the republican
hindu coalition founder this is not modi
i was misinformed and i apologize for
that we know that they're counties this
time because of the pandemic it was much
bigger
it was much bigger
that's what essentially happened now if
i don't you know first of all let me
also tell you that hindu americans
and india in general
they don't give a hoot about this i'm in
the community i go there travel there
every day they don't
this now really devolves into just like
a mess of a conversation thanks you know
what i feel strongly about our country
and our country's going to hell there it
is it is going to hell ladies and
gentlemen that's what i feel strongly
about and when i look at what's happened
to the us when you look at what's
happened in two years to the united
states we've never been in a position
like this ever
but you know some would say president
trump that this this idea of a of a kind
of a stolen or a illegal election
can have consequences in terms of what
happened in in january 6th some would
say as a consequence of that that there
was actual violence yeah
well democrats have said it even though
democrats have said it for a long time
about different elections what is he
talking about they went out and they
said the 2016 election was stolen the
same people that now complain and of
course this is a false equivalency the
idea that there was an influence
campaign by other countries who
preferred trump over hillary clinton
is not the literal theft of an election
in the way that trump is claiming there
was fraud
were big complainers about 2016. they
say i stole the election in 2016 which i
didn't do but this by the way hillary
conceded like hours after the results
voices that you hear said
no no there's tremendous proof there's
tremendous evidence and again go back to
just
two weeks ago when zuckerberg said he
was told russian misinformation don't
say anything sure don't say anything
until after the election
yeah so there's the i mean just a
bizarre interview here's just one other
clip in which trump was asked about
2024. let me just ask you to see
both of you back together again
is this all an indication that
you are now set on the road to
2024 everyone wants me to run i'm
leading in the polls and every poll the
republican polls and democrat polls and
now that's obviously not true earlier i
told you about a new poll in which joe
biden is leading by six in the
hypothetical matchup but reality does
not matter i'll make a decision in the
very
near future i suspect and i think that a
lot of people are going to be very happy
but we've been friends for a long time
we've been friends from before the last
campaign in 2016 and then 2020
and i've had a great relationship to
india and to
prime minister
modi we're uh we've been friends and i
think he's a great guy and doing a
terrific job
it's not an easy job he's got so uh but
we've known each other a long time good
man right
that's an interesting thing you said
that you said you're still making up
your mind but a lot of people will be
happy with the decision i think so a lot
of people will be and a couple of people
will be unhappy
okay this is quite an interesting uh
hint that we've got there charlotte you
you think it's now almost a done deal
that president trump is
going to run again and should he run
again is he is he the obvious choice of
course he should run again that's our
view and then you know it'll be great if
he runs again i mean our community they
will just love to have uh yeah the
indian community will just absolutely
love trump and the hindu community will
love trump by the way
two communities that don't particularly
love trump but that's the claim that's
being made
what a wild interview truly bizarre
stuff and again this this
you know the right used to claim very
loudly
no matter what ever happens in the
united states you never say america
isn't great you never say america is
downhill or going bad or whatever
and now it's completely acceptable among
these folks to say no no no america
sucks now you need me to fix it and make
it good america's going to hell in the
bush era
republicans would say you never say that
very very different republican party at
this point in time all right before we
get to voicemails i want to tell you
about something which
it's one of these things where like it
very clearly seems like a lie
but if it were true it's almost even
worse there's a very interesting rolling
stone article
which says
that trump told his white house team
that he needed to protect quote
russiagate documents okay so understand
this is the assertion being made and
we'll talk about whether it's true
the former president who left the white
house with a trove of sensitive material
believes there are documents that would
expose a deep state plot against him and
told confidants he needed to protect
them
from the next administration so really i
mean this is crazy
but think about what it is that is it is
being being asserted here in this
rolling stone article
in his final days at the white house
trump told advisers
he needs to preserve certain
russia-related documents
to keep his enemies from destroying them
ah okay
the documents relate to the federal
investigation into russia election
meddling and alleged collusion with
trump's campaign
at the end of his president presidency
trump and his team pushed to declassify
these so-called russia gate documents
believing they would expose a deep state
plot against him
according to a person with direct
knowledge of the situation and another
source briefed on the matter trump told
several people working in and outside
the white house he was concerned that
biden's administration or the quote deep
state would shred
bury or destroy the evidence that trump
was wronged
this is a newly relevant claim based on
the fbi search so let's kind of talk
through this right
if it is true
that donald trump believed he had to
steal documents
because they exposed the deep state plot
against him which the biden
administration would shred and destroy
that is bonkers nuts
but there's a second layer to this stuff
just because trump said that's what he
believed doesn't mean it's actually what
he believed and what i mean by that is
if these documents really exonerated
trump
why would he want to take them and hide
them
these would be things you would want to
publicize
and you can't rule out that this is
something that's being brought up now to
try to justify donald trump taking the
documents that he took so so there's
like three or four different layers to
this thing but again
if this was really what trump said and
what trump believed he is essentially q
anon right if the republican party
essentially elected q anon to the
presidency when they elected donald
trump
but because it's trump we never want to
ignore the possibility
that this is only what some are claiming
trump said and he didn't really say it
third possibility that this is true
something trump said but didn't mean
there's also you you have to assume
everybody might be lying the people now
telling rolling stone trump said this
might be lying trump might have said it
but might have been dishonestly saying
it to create plausible deniability over
taking the documents
anything is true
it's a stack of lies it's it's like
those russian matryoshka dolls where you
open the doll and there's a smaller and
smaller doll in it it's lies and
deception and lies and deception all
baked together almost like a beef
wellington of sorts i think maybe is the
way i would describe it really wacky
wacky stuff
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
here's a great voicemail from the eggman
you know i spoke about my time up north
in uh the hudson valley recently in new
york and i mentioned you go north you go
west it gets more and more conservative
the eggman called in who lives way out
there and he said david the hudson
valley is nothing you should see what
goes on where i live
hey dave i like how you describe new
york and how you said the further north
or west you get in new york state the
further conservative yes
it gets i live in western new york dave
i live a half hour from niagara falls
okay that's how western new york i'm
well not that close but
we are so
uh western new york i call it west
virginia new york right there's more
dale earnhardt oh three
nascar and trump flags around here than
you would even see in florida yeah
absolutely insane really there are a ton
of confederate flags
you would think that we're in the south
so the caller from texas yesterday who
told you about all the right-wing
anti-trump uh let's go brandon flags he
described west virginia new york when
you talk about the hudson valley i don't
think you have any idea how red it is up
here
i grow a large beard and drive an old
pickup truck just to be incognito just
so they won't kill me for being a jew oh
god shalom brother yeah so i mean
obviously the area eggman is describing
is very different you know hudson val
lots of jewish folks gay folks in hudson
valley uh and no need to be
hiding incognito the way that the egg
man describes hiding as a jewish man in
uh in western new york so yes i i am
aware
that hudson valley is not nearly as
right-wing as the areas that eggman is
talking about but uh yeah no the further
you get from new york city in uh new
york state the wackier and wackier that
it gets we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today chuck schumer
is uh going to be holding a same-sex
marriage vote why why isn't this a
settled issue well there's a pr reason
why it's being done and we're going to
talk about it on the bonus show secondly
we're going to dive deep into the
jackson mississippi water crisis and
we're going to tie this into economic
justice we're going to tie this into
climate change it is a major story it is
another major water crisis many people
familiar with flint michigan this is now
another water crisis in jackson
mississippi and thirdly there is a
california school district asking the
families of the students
to rent out rooms to the teachers in the
school district
what
why is that happening it may or may not
surprise you all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show you can sign
up at joinpacman.com
and get instant access to the bonus show
you can also if you're waiting
for the exact perfect time to get a
membership for all of the stars to align
for there to be a so-called double
rainbow and point to a membership on
both ends of the rainbow um get on my
newsletter at davidpakman.com
because on 9 19 september 19th
we are doing a massive
membership discount and you need only
beyond my newsletter to be notified
alright so i would love to see you on
the bonus show today but if you're
waiting for the 919 special i also
understand and either way we'll be back
with a new show for you tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks
using my link below